the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
guess last time on Friday we went over
the first half of a class very quickly
and so today we're going to go over the
second half of a class very quickly okay
so that was stuff about double and
triple integrals and vector calculus in
the plane and in space
so as usual what's on the final
basically what was on the artist exactly
the same stuff
well not the same problems unfortunately
but so the first thing we learned about
was double integrals in the plane and
how to set up the bounds and how to
evaluate them okay so just to remind you
quickly the important thing with
isolated integrals when you integrate a
function f of X Y say dy DX for example
is that you have to draw a picture of
the region you know unless it's
completely obvious you should really
draw some picture of the domain of
integration and once you have a picture
you can use it to find the bounds so
remember the general method is that we
first look at the inner integral so here
integral of f dy and in this inner
integral the outer variable here X is
fixed so that means we are slicing our
region by a vertical line corresponding
to a fixed value of x so we fix a value
of x and what we have to find out is the
bounds for Y so the value of y at this
point the value of y at that point let
me call that Y sub bottom of X in
general depends of X and this one will
be y at the top and it also depends on X
and then the dance for white would be
like this and then when you look at the
outer bound things are different because
where you expect to have just numbers no
longer functions of anything and what
you do is you look at the shadow of your
region so what do I mean by shadow you
just project to the x-axis okay so if
you project to the x-axis your region
will look like this so its shadow is
going to be this interval from some
minimum value of X to some maximum value
of X and that will give us the bounds -
so it will bounce for the outer integral
and then to evaluate we evaluate the
usual way
so speaking of evaluation what you need
to know for the final well essentially
the same kind of evaluation techniques
that we were supposed to know for the
our tests that means the usual functions
substitutions basic trig stuff like that
okay if well I don't expect that you
would need integration by parts or Foe I
still hope that some of you remember it
from single variable calculus if there's
a need to integrate some big power of
cosine of sine then the formula will be
given to you the weights in the nose
okay and of course we know also how to
set up these integrals in polar
coordinates
and then the array element becomes rdrd
theta and because you integrate first
over our well first of all you should
remember you know the polar coordinate
formulas namely x equals R cosine theta
and y equals R sine theta and second you
should remember that what we do when we
have our vision is for a fixed value of
theta we look for the bounds for R just
like before so the way we're slicing the
region is now we are actually shooting
Ray's straight from the origin and in a
given direction we're asking ourselves
how far does my region go so you have to
find a bound you have to find whatever
the value of R will be out here as a
function of theta and ways to do that
can be geometric or they can be by
starting from the XY equation of
whatever 12 you have and then expressing
it in terms of R and theta and solving
for R so for example just to illustrate
it we've seen in a one of our like
classics has been the circle of radius 1
centered at 1 0 so this guy you have two
different ways of getting its polar
coordinates equation one is to argue
geometrically that you have a right
angle in here and this length is two
this angle is Theta this length is R so
the polar equation is R equals two
cosine theta the other way to do it if
somehow you're missing the geometric
trick is to start from the XY equation
what's the X way equation of this guy
well it's X minus 1 squared plus y
squared equals 1 so if you expand that
you'll get x squared minus 2x plus 1
plus y squared equals 1 then Y is so
everyone's simplify X square plus y
square becomes R squared minus 2x
becomes R cosine theta
equals zero that gives you when you
simplify by R equals two cosine theta
two ways to get the same polar equation
okay I should say this is an example in
case you were wondering what I was doing
okay so we've also actually seen how to
change variables to more complicated
coordinate systems let's say UV
coordinates but of course you can call
them whatever you want so the main thing
to remember is that you have to look for
the Jacobian which will give you the
conversion ratio between DX dy and dudv
so for example if you know U and V as
functions of x and y then you will write
the U DV equals absolute value of the
Jacobian partial UV over partial XY
times DX dy or if it's easier for you
you can do the Jacobian the other way
around and this Jacobian remember is the
determinant of the 2 by 2 matrix that
you obtain by putting the partial
derivatives of U and V with respect to X
and y so then when we have that we can
change the integrand f of X Y into
something that involving U and V
possibly and then we have to find the
bounds and to find the bounds perhaps
perhaps the easiest is to draw a picture
of a region in UV coordinate so you know
maybe you have some picture in the
xy-plane that might actually be really
hard to draw and maybe in the in terms
of U and V the picture will become much
simpler it might just become a rectangle
of course if you see immediately what
the bounds are in terms of U and V and
they turn out to be very easy then you
may maybe you don't even have to the
whole this picture but if it's not
completely obvious then that may
be a helpful way of figuring out what
the bounds will be when you switch from
XY to UV okay so we've seen some
problems like that and there's more
internals in case you need more
questions yes well that's the second
time you asked for something real quick
in these review sessions you're in a
hurry take your time take your time okay
so partial UV other partial XY that's
just going to be the determinant of U
sub X u sub y V sub X V sub y that's the
definition okay that's quite a joint
okay and of course a general
common-sense thing that applies to
actually all the integrals that we are
going to see there's two things in the
integral one is whatever you integrate
it's called the integrand could be a
function here it's a vector field in
some of the flux things and so on
there's another thing which is the
region over which you integrate okay and
the two have strictly nothing to do with
each other so you know when you're given
a piece of data in the statement of a
problem you have to figure out whether
that's part of a function to be
integrated or whether that's part of the
region of integration it is the region
of integration then it will go into the
bounds of the integral and maybe in the
choice of the coordinate system that you
will use for integrating while the
function that you're integrating goes
you know before the DX dy and not into
the bounds or anything like that I know
it sounds kind of silly but that's you
know it's a good safety check you know
ask yourselves when you have a piece of
data where in my formula should this go
yes
yes in case you want to bounce for this
region in polar coordinates indeed it
would be double integral for so our for
a fixed theta R goes from zero to
whatever it is on that curve so that
would be zero to two cosine theta of
whatever the function is Rd Rd theta and
the bounds on theta would be from
negative PI over two to PI over two okay
we've seen that one several times so
hopefully by now it's clear okay let me
move on a bit because we have a lot of
other kinds of integrals to see
so another kinds of integrals we've seen
are triple integrals and I'm putting
them here I mean I'm not doing things in
the order that we did them in the class
just so that you know you can see
parallels between stuff in the plane and
in space so when we do triple integrals
in space well it's the same kind of
story except now we have of course more
coordinate systems we have rectangular
coordinates we have cylindrical
coordinates and we have spherical
coordinates and really cylindrical
coordinates only mean that we are
instead of XY and Z we are replacing X
and y by the polar coordinate in the XY
plane so the angle theta and the
distance R so R is somehow the distance
from the z axis and z is behind
okay so usually you don't have to choose
between rectangular and cylindrical
until somewhat late in the process
especially if you integrate first of all
Z because then the choice will come up
mostly when you try to figure out
whatever bounds for the shadow of your
region when the Z part looks exactly the
same in rectangular and in cylindrical
spherical isn't the other hand a little
bit more annoying because it looks quite
different
but you should think of it as doing
polar coordinates not only in the
horizontal direction but also in the
vertical direction at the same time so
you so you have this angle fee that
measures the angle down from the
positive z axis and you have Rho which
is the distance from the origin and see
if I project to the z axis so R becomes
a whole sign fee and Z becomes Rho
cosine fee so I hope that you all know
these two formulas but if you ever have
you know a small somehow memo elapsed
during the final then you should
consider drawing this kind of picture
because it will come from you know it
will let you check very quickly which
one is sine which one is cosine now of
course we have to have formulas for DV
in all these coordinate systems so here
for example that might be DZ rdrd theta
Rd Rd theta DZ or any thing like that
here that might be a whole squared sine
fee times D Rho D Phi D theta and the
general method for setting up bounds is
pretty much the same as in the plane
just as one more step so if you're doing
rectangular or cellular coordinates with
Z first for example that's the most
common well if you do the first then you
have to actually start by figuring out
for a given value of x and y or n theta
where you know what is the portion of a
vertical line above X Y that lies within
my region so that will go from Z on the
bottom of the surface which depends on
the bottom of my solid which depends on
x and y 2z at the top of my solid which
also usually will depend on x and y and
so that will give me the bounds for DZ
and then I will be left with the shadow
of my region in the XY plane and that
one I will set up like a double integral
over where
okay strictly speaking if you are
curious we could also change to weird
coordinate systems using jacobians with
three variables at the same time but we
haven't seen that so it won't be on the
final but it would work just the same
way just with more pictures to go
and in fact I just wanted to say this
whole squared sign fee it's actually the
Jacobian for the change of variables
from rectangular to spherical
coordinates okay let's not think too
much about that so applications well
we've seen how to use double or triple
integrals to find the area of a volume
of a piece of a plane or a piece of
space and find also the mass so when R
is just double integral of 1 da the
volume is triple integral of 1 DV
sometimes if it's a volume between the
XY plane and the graph of some function
you can just set it up directly as a
double integral but there's no harm in
doing it as a triple integral if you
feel better about that and mass will be
well double or triple integral depending
on how many dimensions you have of
whatever density function you have da or
DV then does how to find the average
value of some function
and so the owner weighted average well
let me do the free dimensional case okay
you'll just replace volume by area and
DV by D a and so on if need be so that
would be one of our volume of the solid
times the triple integral of F DV or if
it's a weighted average one of our mass
times the triple integral of the
function times density times DV okay so
if you don't have a density or identity
is constant then that it uses to that
one
others we've seen well so in particular
we've seen enough enough center of mass
so the center of mass is just given by
taking the average values of the
coordinates X bar Y bar X bar Y bar z
bar so it's just this formula but taking
X Y or Z as a function there's moments
of inertia for example the moment of
inertia about the z axis is the triple
integral of x-squared plus y-squared
density DV or if you have just a
two-dimensional object then it's the
same formula but of course with da and
then we call that the polar moment of
inertia because we thought of it as
rotating the plane about the origin but
the origin is just where the z axis hits
the XY plane so it's really the same
thing and we've also seen gravitational
attraction in space and I let you look
at your notes for that it's just one
formula to remember ok questions about I
directed integrals things like that yes
so okay so what I mean okay so the
formula that you should know about
notation attraction is that if you have
a point mass at the origin and you have
some solid centered on the z axis let's
add I think it then the force will be
given by so G times the mass times the
triple integral of density times cosine
fee of our whole squared times DV and of
course you will actually do that in
cycle coordinates because it's easier
that way if that's the formula I have in
mind let's see all these formulas just
give you you know examples of things to
integrate and how to set up the bounds
and so on does not depend on what you're
actually integrating it's done always
using the same methods okay let's move
on work and line integrals
so we've seen how to do that in the
plane and in space
and it looks very similar somehow so
remember you have to know how to set up
and evaluate a line integral of this
form and concretely what you do so if
you're in space well let me do it in the
plane this time if you're in the plane
you have two components and then this
becomes the line integral of M DX plus n
dy if you have a space curve then you
will have a third component you will add
that guidance DZ now how do we evaluate
that well it's very different from there
because here we are just on a curve so
there should be only one degree of
freedom so one variable should be enough
to know where we are so we'll have to
express x and y in terms
well if Z and Z optionally if there's
one in terms of a single parameter and
that might be just one of the
coordinates you know if you're told y
equals x squared that's easy you just
substitute y equals x squared and dy
equals 2x DX into everything and you're
left with an integral over X maybe it
will be something in terms of time or in
terms of an angle
some people are having a lot of fun
there okay so we express having in terms
of a single parameter and that will give
us you know a usual single integral any
questions about that
yes so if you can't paralyze the curl
then it's available II helped with that
with the line integral because you know
well you might be able to very
technically into a computer but most
likely I mean that's you know that's the
easiest way to describe a curve so
indeed it could be that in the plane you
have an equation in terms of x and y
given by some completed formulas
defining some curve so then actually
there are ways you can use basically
differentials and constraint partials to
figure out what actually the tangent
vector to the curve is and so on but we
haven't really seen how to do that so
that would be a really nice topic for
tying together the end of the second
unit that we discussed last time
constrained partials with this stuff but
that's not going to be part of our
topics so basically I mean all the
curves that we've seen in this class
there's a way to express the position of
a point in terms of parameter we haven't
seen any curves that are so complicated
that you can't do it
okay what else
so the other thing we've seen is that
there are some special cases of vector
fields where we don't actually have to
compute this thing because maybe we know
that it's the gradient of some potential
function and then we have a fundamental
theorem that gives us a way to compute
this without computing it okay so we've
seen about gradient fields and path
independence so we've seen that if so
the thing to check is whether the curl
of our vector field is zero okay and
remember in the plane
that's one condition an x equals my in
3d in space that's actually three
conditions because you have to check all
the mixed partials of the various
components so if the curl of F is zero
that tells us we are likely to have a
gradient field strictly speaking I
should mention and F is defined in a
simply connected region
then F is a gradient field so that means
that we can find a potential function
you can write f as the gradient of f of
little F for some potential function
little F and we've seen how to find the
potential in fact we've seen two methods
for that and we've seen them twice we've
seen them once for functions of two
variables one for functions of three
variables they look very much the same I
encourage you to compare your notes for
the two side-by-side to see where they
differ
okay so where they differ lovely
speaking the first well anyone who hits
the first of a second but one of the two
methods was to compute the line integral
so in the plane what we did is we set up
and evaluated a line integral along our
favorite path from the origin to a point
with coordinates say x1 y1 and then we
had to evaluate the line integral for
the work done along this path and that
will give us the value of a potential at
that point if we are doing it with three
variables that method remains very
similar the only difference is now we
have to go also up in space to some
point x1 y1 z1 and so we actually sum
three pieces together but on each piece
into the same story only one variable
changes here it's only X that changes
it's only Y that changes on the third
one uneasy would be changing that's one
possibility
and the other possibility for finding
the potential is that we start with the
condition that you know the first
component of our vector field should be
equal to F sub X for the unknown
potential function so what we do is we
integrate with respect to X and we'll
get our potential function well up to an
integration constant and with
integration constant typically depends
on the remaining variables that might be
Y or if we're in space Y n Z and then
what we have to do is we have to take
the partial of this with respect to Y
and compare it to what we want it to be
namely the Y component of a vector field
and match them to get some information
about this guy and if we have three
variables then there's a third step
because where you still have an unknown
function of Z that you need to get by
comparing the partial with respect to Z
okay may I see a lot of very quiet faces
somehow well hopefully that's because
you know that stuff it's because you're
hopelessly confused then please review a
lot before the final but I really hope
that's not the case
okay so
okay and so in particular what we've
seen is once we have the potential then
we can use a fundamental theorem of
calculus to tell us that if we have a
line integral to compute from work along
a curve that goes from some point p0
some point p1 then the line integral for
the work done by gradient F is actually
going just to be the change of the
change in the value of the potential and
in particular that doesn't depend on how
we got from p0 to p1 that's why we say
that we have path independence okay next
topic that flux in plane and space so
flux looks quite different in the plane
and in space because in the plane it's
just another kind of line integral while
in space it's a surface integral if you
were in four-dimensional space it would
be a triple integral I mean general you
do flux for something that's somehow you
know a wall that separates regions of
space from each other
[Music]
so in the plane the way we do it is we
have a curve C and we look at its
tangent vector let's call that T and we
rotate it by 90 degrees clockwise let's
our convention to get a unit normal
vector that points to the height of the
curve as we move along the curve
so let's our convention for renting
curves and we are always going to be
using that one so N equals T rotated 90
degrees clockwise so in particular that
means that NDS which will be in what we
integrate against when we try to compute
flux that will just end up being dy
comma negative DX okay so concretely
when we have to evaluate a line integral
of f dot n D little s so geometrically
we could try to take the dot product of
our field with the normal vector and
then sum the length elements along the
curve and in some cases for example if
you know that the vector field is
tangent to the curve or if the dot
product is constant or things like that
then that might actually give you a very
easy answer but in general the most
efficient way to do it
will be to say that you know if your
vector field has components and let's
call them P and Q then that will be just
the line integral of PQ dot dy comma
negative DX which means negative Q DX
plus P dy and from that point onwards
you evaluate it exactly the same way as
you would for a work integral but of
course the geometric meaning is very
different it's the same meaning that
we've always seen for
perhaps it measures how much the vector
field goes across for golf okay
now if we're in space then you take flux
for a surface not for a curve and so it
will work is that you have to choose an
orientation of the surface which just
means choosing one of the two possible
unit normal vectors and then you will do
a surface integral for f dot n yes so
that's the surface area element so the
set up for this surface integral is that
first we have to express and NDS in some
way so one possibility is that we can
express the normal vector n gs
geometrically that's for example what we
do when we look at a horizontal plane or
vertical plane or a sphere or cylinder
then we have some geometric idea of why
the normal vector is what it is and we
have some formula for years oh we can
use one of the standard formulas so
basically we've seen two formulas that
work in fairly general situations so one
of them says so we need more space for
that so if s is given by an equation Z
equals some function of XY then you can
just say NDS equals minus F sub X minus
F sub y one dxdy and I need to rewrite
that because I'm running out of space
but while I array is I would like to
point out the most important thing in
here okay when I say NDS equals blah
blah blah times DX dy
dxdy is not the same thing as DS at all
okay if you make that mistakes you're
going to go into trouble the next time
that you try to buy a real estate in a
region with you know Hills or cliffs or
things like that the S is the area on
the slanted surface dxdy is the area on
the map that shows the xy-plane and
these are not the same thing so in
particular in particular
you cannot just you know take one piece
of it and not the other piece because n
whether to let me give you formulas for
and unfold es directly just to convince
you and that way you know if you feel
that you need them then you'll have them
so actually n is minus F sub X minus F
sub y comma 1
but scaled down to unit length this is
not a unit vector so it's actually
divided by the length of this guy which
is at x squared plus FY squared plus 1
and D s is that same factor times DX dy
and so the two magically you know the
square roots cancel out when you
multiply them together but it would be
completely wrong to you know just say I
love a place NDS by minus F sub X minus
F sub y + 1 and then I end up again with
ideas and I do something else with es
that's that's a pretty bad conceptual
mistake because it gives you the wrong
answer another option more general than
that if we haven't seen how to solve for
Z how to express Z as a function of x
and y well maybe we still know some
normal vector to the surface then
there's another formula for NDS which is
up to sign and divide it by n dot k DX
dy and see actually that projection
formula works also if you have to
project to another coordinate plane for
example if you want project to the X Z
coordinate plane the relation between
NDS and DX DZ is given by n over N J J
is the direction perpendicular to the XZ
plane but I mean this one is more useful
okay so what's a good example of that is
for example if you have a slanted plane
given to you you can easily find its
normal vector let's just given by the
coefficients of X Y Z in the equation
another situation where that might
happen is if your surface is given by an
equation of the form G of X Y Z equals
zero that's the case then you know this
is a level set of G and we know how to
find a normal vector to the level set
namely the gradient vector is always
perpendicular to the level set so you
would take the gradient of G to be your
begin ok so now these are basically all
the integrals we've seen how to set up
and now we have a bunch of theorems
relating them ok so let me think about
how I'm going to organize that well let
me try like this okay so this part of a
board will be work this part of the
board will be about flux and the left
part of a board will be about things in
the plane fulfill the right one will be
about things in space ok so what have we
seen
well we've seen greens theorem for work
ok that doesn't work so well because
it's too smooth so I'm going to actually
use my black box to do that
okay so this side will be space this
side will be the plane and we are going
to start with theorems about work and
we'll see theorems about flux pretty
soon so we have two theorems about work
in the plane that's called greens
theorem in space that's called Stokes
theorem
okay so greens theorem says if I have a
closed curve in the plane going
counterclockwise and closing entirely
some region R then the line integral
along c for the work of F is equal to
the double integral over the region
inside of the curl of F da concretely if
my components of F are called
m and n that's the line integral of M DX
plus n dy is equal to the double
integral over R of n sub X minus M sub y
G so this side here is a usual line
integral this side here is a usual
double integral in the plane and somehow
their values end up being magically
related
well not quite magically we've actually
seen how to prove it but you know okay
and now the analog of that in space is
Stokes theorem Stokes says if I have a
closed curve in space okay so now I have
to decide what kind of thing it bounds
and the answer is it will have to bound
some surface but I have a choice of
surface okay so I choose my favorite
surface bounded by C well I'll just wait
like that and we have to choose a
compatible orientation so we um go we've
seen this right
all for choosing how to iron the surface
I believe in this case if I take see
like that when the normal vector has to
go up and then it tells me how to
compute the work done by F along see
namely that becomes the double integral
over that surface s of curl F which I
will write as del cross F dot NDS okay
so this line integral it's a usual line
integral but just you know if for some
reason we don't want to compute it
directly we can actually replace it by a
surface integral over any surface
bounded by the curve so it might be that
the problem will tell you which surface
you have to consider it might be that
you'll be left to choose the simplest
possible surface you can think of that
somehow having this curve as its
boundary okay and so now remember curl
of a vector field in space is going to
be another vector expression it has
three components and the way you compute
it is not by remembering the actual
formula which is really complicated but
they instead computing the cross product
between Dell and F so you set up because
product of course it's a highly symbolic
cross product I mean it's not an actual
cross product of actual vectors but it
works the same way okay so both of these
formulas basically relate work on a
curve with what happens to the curl on
the surface that's enclosed by this
curve that's bounded by this curve and
just in this one you have less freedom
of choice because you don't have somehow
you know a z direction in which you
could move your surface so there's only
one possible choice of surface there's
only one thing that enclosed by this
curve in the plane in both cases that
these things tell you that you can think
of curl as measuring how much the field
fails to be concern
see if your field was conservative if
the curl was zero then the right hand
side would just be zero and that would
be fortunate because if the curl is zero
then your field is conservative that
means it comes from a potential that
means when you go along the closed curve
well the change of value of a potential
should be zero and if I would say this
path independence tells you no work and
of course if you have a vector field
that's not a gradient field then the
curl is not necessarily zero and when
you get a more interesting answer
finally let's move on to the theorems
about flux so that's green for flux and
that's the divergence theorem
so flux theorems so here I say that will
be divergence and here that will be
moving again so greens theorem for flux
says if I have a closed curve that goes
counterclockwise around some region so
in particular counterclockwise means
that the normal vector will be going out
of the region and then it tells us that
the flux out of the region for the curve
C so that will be the line integral of F
dot NDS is equal to the integral over
the region inside of div F da and
remember the divergence of MN is just M
X plus NY this one here with the
virgin's theorem tells you something
similar but now for a region of space
bounded by a closed surface so if you
have some region of space and you call
its boundary surface s and you let n be
the normal vector that goes you know out
of the region R so you orient as
outwards yeah then the flux out of the
region through s is going to be the same
as the triple integral over the region
of divergence F DV again remember the
divergence of a vector field with
components P Q R is px plus qy plus RZ
so what do these two theorems say well
they say it's actually the same thing
they say the total flux out of a region
is equal to the integral of divergence
of whatever's inside
and the reason for that is again we've
seen for a velocity field the divergence
measures how much things are expanding
or how much stuff is being created it
tells you the amount of sources per unit
portion of the region so when you sum
that over everything you get the amount
of fluid that's being you know the total
amount of sources inside here and that
tells us how much stuff has to go out
per unit time that's basically the
interpretation so in a way I'd be
tempted to say that you know this table
of four theorems is somehow the
culminating point of 1802 and you'd do
well to remember them however I'd like
also to point out that these films are
completely useless if you don't know how
to compute any of the integrals that are
in there so all the stuff that was
around there before is actually somehow
more fundamental and if you don't know
how to compute the double or triple
integrals then this is a filter use to
you okay so that's the end I guess I
have to wish you happy holidays
[Applause]